a questo ci tieni si iscrive porca
[ __ ] stefano good guys c'è anche in
surreal power che ho effettivamente
detto che non si vedeva ma lo faccio
vedere con da basso la spalla si vede ma
ragazzi allora qui a tokyo vendono un
sacco di pacchetti di figurine di
pokémon yu gi oh io chi cazzo
ciao sabri regalo questo pacchetto di
foto la polaroid
ma questo era un video serio i quattro
di esse da piccolo ero un fan accanito
dei pokémon ma bovo pazzo maniaco io e
stefano abbiamo deciso di prendere un
miliardo di pacchetti di pokémon e di
fare l'unboxing il problema è che io le
nuove generazioni di pokémon non le
conosco ho preso questo non so se si
vede faccio tipo come cliomakeup che fa
vedere dei trucchi solo che io faccio
vedere le carte dei pokémon perché sono
più serio questo pack che hanno fatto
dovrebbe essere per l'anniversario ecco
infatti anniversario dei 20 anni di
pokémon perfetto 9 ci sono tutte le
carte dell'edizione vecchia let's go for
the scatole shaun porca [ __ ] animale
eccola sapeva squarci sulle mani a parte
questa questa sensazione questa questa
di avere questi pacchetti monaco si muro
non ho mai avuto in tutta la mia vita
sti cazzi però non faccia troppo schifo
siete pronti corto anni che merda una
cacata dopo l'altra duo pikachu kakul
chelsea cazzo cioè le altre fanno
abbastanza schifo
tranne hunter che figo questa ragazzi me
la ricordo ce l'avevo quando no non è
vero non ce l'ho mai avuta questa però
la vedi tu porca [ __ ] stefano ti odio
e ritrite sulle visto piccoli ma sai che
non ti ho visto mai nella vita
ma che bello questo pokemon forte a
questo ci tieni
ovviamente gli ho detto che ci tenevo
questa qua ma in realtà è una merda però
vabbè non impara perché sappiamo se vi
dicevo che ci tenevo all'altra e rame a
qualche piatto preferito sì che trovo il
mio poche un preferito del resto con
poche mondo cerca voluto rosi che si
sono online per essendo di affetto la
posso fare
lo sapevo ho sentito il bip ho sentito
il vip della camera lo sapevo se degli
stronzi io volevo solo spacchettare
delle carte non è una casa lazio ci vede
ricca sotto ho visto battuto in mezzo ma
più pacato trova il bel po nita magni
mai un cazzo
una fretta che schifo gli spicchi
mi spieghi che kick ass da un po di mal
di gola
sarà un video se doveva essere uno
spacchettamento black swan
simone era una donna così tanta vita
ogni polizza veramente così tanta vita
a cambiare è bello fare video in
compagnia con saluto dai nuovi tifi roma
l'ho venduto la mia anima mi capire
questo lato firma guarda si rifiuta
anche di farla vedere l'autofocus dai
bella sembra di terza elementare puoi
charming per la madonna
no ma se non ci sto credendo che cazzo
ma epici 8 ma come leva così tanto devo
consultarmi con stefano ma mi consulterò
dopo perché non c'è sempre magica black
a o con 400 di questi miei hungary da
sei ragazzi di pin pokémon go guido
ne ho trovati due di magica però sono
bastati per gary di quanto forte quanto
adesso la [ __ ] che mi viene a trovare a
casa che cazzo stai facendo questa
stoffa c'è ma perché state facendo sì
che i problemi ci sono e va beh niente
ogni volta trovo dell'ex ragazzi sono
pieno di ex che vita di merda avrei
preferito charlize a mille volte però il
gas l'icac una star hugh sei stato un
parto maledetta cartacea no ragazzi
cielo o anche charm ilio mi manca
charman e il cazzo altre volte ciari
hyatt e vabbè minchia quanti il cio
doppione regali di ieri lo se poi
trovato un biglietto sono troppo figli a
vedersi però questo è nettamente più
potente infatti mi sa che questo vale di
più da intel fighissimo troppo figo che
poi tra l'altro che cazzo est executor
con la madonna cos'è sta roba perché c'è
una carta storta ok ma non ci voglio mai
credere ma davvero sono super contento
che se ne perde uno show l'altro sono
tutte le rare che ho trovato fino adesso
sono tutte queste che sono abbastanza
abbiamo char izzard che quella che
dovevo trovare che mi ero prefissato che
trovate due quindi perfetto questa qui
che non ho ben capito perché così nido
queen rights nights questo vale charman
e l'ho messo solo perché così posso far
evolvere in char milian per poi farle
volevano in charlie's ora quindi lo
mettono partigiano sceglie tutti e tre
gli è questo executor che non ho ben
capito che cazzo è però va bene hitman
jean youn pgt es
ieri dos che ne ho due tra l'altro mini
ragazzi via lo scambio volentieri venosa
all ex nido queen anche quest'anno due
censi poli one e two
ma ciò che questo fa anche abbastanza
kacar e quindi [ __ ] p geo tex
questo ancora più cazzuto rimoldi prima
come ultimo game
una volta arrivati a questo punto queste
qui in città o in realtà dovrei riuscire
a trovarci pokémon delle nuove
generazioni il problema è che non so un
cazzo delle nuove generazioni quindi in
teoria adesso me la guardo
però la maggior parte non li conosco
perchè io conosco solo la vecchia
generazione però già che ci sono
gustiamo pure queste shade la conosco
ora aveva le conosco tutte no questa non
la conosco sto scherzando allora li ho
preparati e tutte ragazzi qui dentro ci
sono all'incirca sei pacchetti e faccio
un unboxing unico cioè le scarto tutti
di fila così almeno vediamo le altre da
mia mano stesso ebbe qualcuno che non
conosco non conosco non conosco questo
cigno porta i cuccioli alle famiglie
ok l'ultima evoluzione di quello starter
d'acqua
vabbè non conosco e cans epoca sappiamo
che questo è uno yorkshire uscito male
questo perché conosco belle le nuove
generazioni non conosco un cazzo ride on
electric minchia quello quello pokemon
rubinho non ricordo questo non ha idea
di chi sia ma sembra molto figo lo tengo
questo non so chi si assume uno
sterminio che sto qua sembra carino però
è un cazzo di pesce nel calde lavoro del
turno il candelabro del turno ma questa
sembra una carta che non è una carta ok
faceva nido queen e ultimo en faro non
importa perché c'è stefano chi è qui
apposta il mio rai tra tutte dotate
quello che mi piace di meno solo giusta
fammi vedere che alla faccia momento
vedere rai e che cazzo ti piace di
strike poca di questo incontro di
ricerca ho visto che nei 22 button
aspetta aspetta del monte carlo tavolo
sedere a un tavolo scambiare la teiera
rifiuto è l'unica che scambierei per
rai5 momento chi è posto avevano la
faccia vedere prima gli altri allora no
arci un locale cosa vuoi rai c'erano
almeno una gara non è anche una rara
visto che ti voglio bene ti regalo dark
ride
basterà gap live ad apprendere molte ma
io lo amo questo uomo perché stefano è
così buono non è normale ma come fa
calcare bellissimo altri fanno cagare
alle altre rispetto a questa band cambio
effettuato un ragazzino terrà stiamo
facendo scambi commerciali che minchia
il mercato nero spostati come me ne
acquisterò baba faye sito non capisci un
cazzo ma che cazzo ecco avevo scartato
ma perché altri possano puntare no papà
dopo che cazzo poi lasciamo in passivo
no dai di me odio lo intendo la porta in
faccia bene giuseppe nel mezzo basso
quindi ragazzi stanno in questo video
che si è strano vi sia piaciuto perché
volevo assolutamente farlo è stato un po
un tuffo nel passato per l'argomento è
un mi piace se avete capito scambiare
niente descrizioni che io so queste
hanno seguito aspetta chi delle figlie
che cosa c'è cellulare di menisco
insacca un pisa che viste le tipiche per
questa non sai ke kazzo opera col
ministro sotto accanto
la lista che valgono la canto io ti ho
appena finito di fare ordine con tutti i
pacchetti della scrivania e ne avevo
dimenticato uno e ho trovato questo che
credo sia correggetemi se sbaglio o
rayquaza ex omega rai quasi uno dei due
di vedere la reazione di stefano
successo del bosque lo scherzetto a casa
è per tu destino sei rimasto lì lo stavo
per buttare invece premesso la cosa che
era un pacchetto con una carta sopra
porca [ __ ] qui al 100 certo tipo e
che ti aiuta che c'è qui ma stai
scherzando
niente raga io penso di esser messo male
non è vero chi cazzo di poi tutte
insieme a 20 c metti a spacchetta
staranno sì